you are watching cold fusion tv
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
wikileaks has been making news around
the world in recent years
but what is it exactly in this video
we'll take a look
as a disclaimer no i'm not going to be
talking about any political aspects
or even talking about what the documents
from wikileaks say
no political stuff in this video this is
going to be purely historical
and factual life is too short for
internet fights
let's get into it in a nutshell
wikileaks is a journalist organization
that publishes news leaks via
its website the leaks are from
completely anonymous sources
the website was founded in iceland in
2006 by julian assange an australian
computer programmer
julian assange has been a hacker since
1987 and was extremely good at his craft
in the late 80s and early 90s while
living in melbourne assange managed to
hack the pentagon
u.s department of defense navy nasa
motorola panasonic lockheed martin and
xerox
in 1991 assange was finally caught by
the australian federal police but was
released on good behavior and in a twist
began helping the police in 1993.
julian was also involved in starting one
of the first public internet service
providers in australia later that year
after a few ventures and some study at
the university of melbourne
assange founded wikileaks more on julian
and his current situation later
but back to wikileaks wikileaks is run
by volunteers from a number of countries
and is a non-profit organization
in the past 10 years they've released
more secret documents than all of the
world's media combined
a total of 10 million as a side note
wikileaks has no affiliation with
wikipedia and the two shouldn't be
confused
so what is the goal of wikileaks
according to the wikileaks website
its goal is quote to bring important
news and information to the public
one of our most important activities is
to publish original source material
alongside our news stories so readers
and historians alike
can see evidence of truth end quote
wikileaks actually doesn't do any of the
hacking or uncovering of sensitive
information themselves but acts more of
a middleman
passing on documents that were submitted
to them onto the press
contrary to popular belief the leaking
of documents may actually be completely
legal according to the us supreme court
the supreme court ruled that the united
states constitution
guarantees anonymity to those who reveal
documents in the context of political
discourse
political discourse basically means the
free conversation or discussion of
political topics and issues
[Music]
in other countries outside the u.s such
as china parts of the african continent
and the middle east such leaks could be
punishable by death
there have been several supreme court
precedent cases where the american
constitution protects the publication of
illegally gained information
if the publishers didn't break any laws
to get it this means that if someone
broke the law to get a document
and willfully gave it to wikileaks and
wikileaks then releases that document to
the press
that's perfectly fine according to the
supreme court
it must be said that for wikileaks to be
protected under the us constitution
it has to be treated as a u.s company
the organization says that they analyse
all the documents for genuine
authenticity and have a 100 record of
being accurate
this comes from the horse's mouth itself
so take that statement as you will
so how does it work wikileaks uses an
online dropbox system
devised by julian assange the system
provides a way to submit documents
online
and send them to a media organization
anonymously
this anonymous dropbox outlet is perfect
for whistleblowers to email sensitive
classified information without
prosecution
for those who may not know a
whistleblower is a person who exposes
legal unethical practices or corruption
within an organization
whistleblowers are usually from within
or have close ties with the accused
company
the anonymity of wikileaks runs pretty
deep the traffic on the website cannot
be tracked
this means that it's impossible to tell
who's browsing the website at any given
time wikileaks keeps close tabs on the
details of the security so i can't tell
you exactly how it all works
the website has no official headquarters
but has web hosting in a former nuclear
bunker in sweden
there are other servers around the world
but the main one isn't sweden
this is mainly because swedish law and
its constitution is also protective over
wikileaks activities
interestingly wikileaks used to be
hosted on amazon web services
which currently hosts other entities
like the cia netflix and tinder
if that sounds like a funny combination
watch my amazon video which will be
linked in the description if you want to
know more
wikileaks ended up being kicked off
amazon servers due to a policy breach
stating that they didn't hold the rights
to the content on their site
while this is technically true it does
smell of an upper management decision
from someone in amazon who got cold feet
as most of you know high up government
officials particularly in the united
states
aren't happy with julian assange and
wikileaks the way to deal with this
is pretty simple we got special ops
forces i mean a dead man can't leak
stuff this guy's a traitor a treasonous
and and he has broken every law of the
united states the guy ought to be
and i'm not for the death penalty so if
i'm not for the death penalty i want to
do it
illegally shoot the son of a it's time
that the obama administration treats
wikileaks for what it is
a terrorist organization whose continued
operation
threatens our security shut it down shut
it down
it is time to shut down this terrorist
organization this terrorist website
wikileaks shut it down attorney general
holder in 2010 there was a joint effort
by mastercard
visa paypal western union and bank of
america to choke off the funds to
wikileaks
they managed to wipe out 95 percent of
their funding
wikileaks now relies on bitcoin for
donations
the us state department specifically has
been going after julian assange
they first tried to pin him with the
espionage act of 1917
but this was difficult because of the
first amendment protection from the
press
they also tried to pin him with charges
on stolen property but the documents are
intellectual and not physical
so it didn't really go anywhere
julian assange is currently in the
ecuadorian embassy in london
and cannot leave without being arrested
and taken to sweden for questioning
the questioning is over sexual assault
charges in which he denies
and two of which have been dropped if
assange is taken to sweden
a sign states that he would be in danger
of being sent to the us
and fears that he would face the death
penalty in february of 2016
the united nations stated that the
science had arbitrarily been detained
and that his detention should be brought
to an end the expert panel called
on the swedish and british authorities
to end
mr assange deprivation of liberty i
think the recommendation is quite clear
respect is physical integrity and
freedom of movement
and afford him the right to compensation
on october 17 2016 after a series of
damaging leaks in relation to the united
states democratic party
ecuador cut internet access to assange
considering he has been stuck
inside this building for over four years
now
you can understand that the internet for
him it's not just very important for
his work as editor of wikileaks it's
also a vital
lifeline his only link really to the
outside world but a few hours ago
the official wikileaks twitter account
wrote a message saying that julian
assange's internet link
has been intentionally severed by what
they said was a state
party with some saying that
investigative journalism is now dead
and that reported truth is a rarity it's
been mass grassroots support for assange
and his organization for being that
middle man that has provided deep
revelations of government to the press
and to the public over the past decade
with the signs in limbo and the threat
of more revealing leaks on the way
who knows what's going to happen next
and with that i'm going to end this
video so thanks for watching guys
it's pretty interesting what's going on
in the world right now give this video a
thumbs up if you liked it and leave a
comment below sharing your thoughts
also feel free to subscribe to this
channel if you've just stumbled across
it
this has been degogo you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking
[Music]
know oh